سلمت السلطات السراليه نحو 80 شهيدا عبر
معبر كرم ابو سالم من الذين تم احتجازهم
واختطافهم من قلب مدينه غزه ومنطقه الشمال
هؤلاء لا تعلم حتى هذه اللحظه يعني ماهيه
اسمائهم او تعدادهم الدقيق لكن وفق
تقديراتهم 80 شهيدا هذه الشاحنه الان التي
دخلت عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم جنوبي شرقي
رفح تتجه باتجاه مستشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف
النجار في مدينه رفح لفحص هذه الجثامين و
حاوله التعرف عليها هنا في طبعا المدينه
وكما نشاهد في هذا المشهد وصول هذه
الشاحنه الكبيره التي تحمل في داخلها
هؤلاء الشهداء وستجري عمليه فحص لهم من
الطبيب الشرعي الفلسطيني هنا في مستشفى
الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح
جنوبيه قطاع غزه وهذه المره الاولى التي
يتم تسليم ثمين الى الجانب عبر المعابر
الرسميه ليتم التعرف عليها ودفنها هنا في
قطاع غزه طبعا جئنا اليوم في هذا الوقت تم
استلام 80 شهيدا ليتم مراتهم في مقبره تل
السلطان في مقبره جماعيه هؤلاء الشهداء
الذين استشهدوا في اثناء هذا العدوان
الصهيوني نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يتغمدهم بواسع رحمته تم حيث تم تجهيز
مقبره جماعيه قرابه 50 مترا لكي يتم دفنهم
في مقبره جماعيه
في هذه الاوقات يصعب التعرف على هويه
هؤلاء وسيتم دفنهم هنا في هذه المقبره كما
تشاهدون امامكم هذه الشاحنه قد وصلت يرافق
هذه الشاحنه طاقم طبي فلسطيني س يعاين هذه
الجثامين ومن ثم سيقومون بدفنها هنا في
هذه المقبره الواقعه الى الغرب من مدينه
رفح هنا جنوبي قطاع غزه وبطبيعه الحال هذه
الجثامين مضى عليها على الاقل شهر كامل
لدى الجانب الاسرائيلي ولم يستطع الطاقم
الفلسطيني هنا التعرف على هويه هؤلاء بعد
نظرا لان يعني بعض ما اجساد هؤلاء تحللت
بحسب الطواقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه
وايضا تنبعث منها روائح والان تتم عمليه
انزال هؤلاء للمقبره ودفنهم في هذا يعني
او في هذه الحفره الكبيره التي اعدت خصيصا
لهؤلاء من اجل يعني مباراتهم الثار بشكل
جماعي
استشهدوا في ظروف غامضه لم يستطع احد
التعرف على هويتهم او القاء نظره الوداع
عليهم هكذا هو الحال ل 80 شهيدا وصلوا
قطاع غزه عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم هان
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح